bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission qui en 27 minutes vous en
apprendra bien plus que certains
discours pourtant de même durée
bonjour aujourd'hui on va parler de
l'union européenne une chimère
bonjour hespel bonjour olivier bonjour à
tous bienvenue à dans ce nouvel épisode
de ses caches alors cette semaine
olivier vous allez nous livrer votre
analyse sur l'union européenne jusqu'à
quel point la pandémie de kobe de 19 à
fragiliser l'union comment lieu
survivra-t-elle à cette crise ce sont
les questions qui vont nous occuper
aujourd'hui adam est cette émission je
vous présente mes excuses c'est par ces
mots à le 2 avril dernier qu'ursula van
der leyen
la présidente de la commission
européenne s'est adressé aux italiens
dans cette lettre la patronne des lieux
a reconnu que l'europe avait tardé à
réagir face à l'épidémie de coronavirus
côté italien on a fustigé une europe
lâche à l'image de ce tweet d'antonio
tajani ancien président du parlement
européen et membre du parti d'opposition
forza italia
olivier comment est-ce qu'on peut
expliquer à ce retard à l'allumage de
l'union européenne face à l'apport à la
cette pandémie aussi tout simple c'est
que quand il ya un problème c'est chacun
pour soi donc il n'ya pas plus ni de
couple franco allemand
on a bien vu que l'allemagne faisait
exactement ce qu'elle voulait pendant
que monsieur macron s'agiter et et
l'italie c'est pareil et tous les pays
européens se sont repliés sur eux mêmes
et ont joué leur carte sans s'occuper de
ce qui se passait ailleurs donc l union
européenne est une chimère elle n'existe
pas et d'ailleurs vous avez on peut pas
le qualifier honnêtement d'euros fob
vous avez même monsieur le maire qui a
dit que si on continuait comme ça
c'était la fin de l'union européenne et
donc c'est pas moi qu'il dit là pour une
fois c'est c'est des gens qui sont
plutôt dans le moule est bien bien
europhile donc
on a vu que c'était totalement
inefficace on a vu que chacun joué sa
carte on a vu que il n'y avait
absolument pas de coordination dit sur
la fermeture des frontières ni sur le
confinement ni sur quoi que ce soit ni
sur les masques qu'on s'amuse à se
piquer les uns les autres off avant on
est dans quelque chose qui n'a rien à
voir avec une union quelconque
alors justement olivier en matière de
politique de santé lieu de vous laver
des 1 dispose de faibles marges de
manoeuvre aussi puisque la santé ne fait
pas partie de ses prérogatives selon le
traité de fonctionnement de lieux
l'union encourage la coopération et
complète les politiques nationales
ce qui veut dire que les états gardent
donc ait la main-mise sur leur politique
de santé est ce qu'il faudrait peut-être
revoir un peu hâlé statut d'abord il
faudrait que il faudrait que les états
aient réellement la main en ce qui
concerne de la france
montrez moi la main parce que pour
l'instant je la vois pas beaucoup en
allemagne
ils ont réussi à tester tout le monde
ils ont réussi à distribuer des masques
à tout le monde où on en est encore à
attendre des masques et à attendre des
des distributions de test donc pour le
coup on n'a vraiment pas la main en
france et en italie
c'est quasi pareil donc les deux les
deux pays
on peut pas dire ont failli complètement
sur leur gestion de crise et l'europe
n'a rien à voir là dedans alors oui en
effet sur les les différentes mesures on
n'a que monsieur le maire a arraché la
deuxième réunion de l'euro
vous avez eu 2 % qui vont être attribués
à la lah à la santé sans contrepartie
pour le mpls pas bon ça arrive à la fin
et on peut pas dire que ce soit quelque
chose qui va changer la face de cette de
cette crise qui n'est pas je vous
rappelle qu'une crise de santé publique
c'est c'est malheureusement devenu une
crise économique majeure
alors olivier avant de passer au volet
économique un concrètement un mot juste
sur ce sondage en italie selon une étude
de moniteurs italia qui a été publié le
13 mars dernier
88 % des italiens estiment que le lieu
ne les aide pas à face au co vite 19 67
% considèrent qu appartenir à l'union
constitue un désavantage
est ce que cette crise actuelle qu'elle
y est donc à l'épidémie de coronavirus
pourrait remettre sur la table l'envi
pour certains pays de quitter le navire
mais de toute façon je vous le dis
depuis longtemps dans cette émission que
l'italie finira par sortir parce que
c'est invivable
mais tout le monde maintenant le dit
c'est ça qui est qui est extraordinaire
même les gens qui l'ont créé cet euro
comme jacques attali jacques attali dans
un dans une conférence dernièrement a
dit que l'euro était quelque chose qui
était mal montée qui ne marcherait
jamais et qui éclaterait parce que c'est
c'est mal monté mais qu' il avait tout
fait aussi pour pourrir la vie des gens
qui qui voudraient en sortir donc on
sait très bien que c'est ses pattes
nabeul cette histoire et les crises le
montre pourquoi ça a fonctionné entre
2000 et 2008 parce qu'il se passait rien
parce que tout allait bien et puis tout
d'un coup en 2008 patatrac une récession
et une première crise de
l'euro en 2011 qu'est ce qui se passe à
ce moment là on voit que les fondations
ont été mal fait ou on a du coup tu
fondation on a quand même fait des idées
de solidarité ou l'allemagne par exemple
a pris en charge certains patients
français
il ya quand même il ya une chaîne de
solidarité qui se fait même s'ils
veulent être objectif c'est pas parce
que vous avez un hôpital à la frontière
qui prend 3 infectés du corps en un
virus français qu' il faut saluer le
l'europe l'union européenne et l'euro
soyons sérieux je veux dire il n'y a
rien qui a été fait tout le monde a tiré
dans son coin et ccc d'aperçu tous enfin
je veux dire maintenant il n'ya pas il
ya même plus de débat on sait que
l'union européenne est morte on sait que
les italiens n'en peuvent plus et qu'
ils vont prendre le premier prétexte
qu'ils auront dans les 24 mois qui vont
suivre le le le le pic de la crise ils
sortiront et à ce moment là vous n'aurez
plus d'union européenne et vous n'aurez
plus d'euros tout simplement parce que
c'est là c'est le troisième pays cette
zone économique et que jamais on ne
pourra continuer avec avec l'italie en
moins donc je pense que le le sujet et
est bien réglé amoa donc vous le disiez
un crise sanitaire mais aussi à crise
économique pour le fonds monétaire
international la récession provoquée par
le court aux navires us pourraient être
pires que celles engendrées par la crise
à des subprimes en 2008 du côté des
chiffres la zone euro elle subirait une
contraction de son pib de 7,5 pour cent
en 2020 avec une chute de 9,1 pour cent
du pib en italie 8 % en espagne 7 % en
allemagne et 7 2% en france en 2021 le
fmi s'attend à un rebond avec une
croissance de 4 7% le fmi et qui précise
je cite l'impact économique est et sera
grave mais plus le vivre
cet arrêté rapidement plus la reprise
sera rapide et forte olivier les
conséquences pour lieux seront plus
graves avec ses crises sanitaires ça va
travailler aussi évidemment toute façon
la crise de 2008 c'était une une petite
crise c'était une récession normale
après un cycle de d'expansion qui a
démarré en 2002 et qui s'est prolongée
jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin 2006 donc on a
une récession qui était parfaitement
classique
alors qui a été légèrement aggravée on
va dire par les subprimes et est donc
par un problème de dette
je vous le rappelle on avait endettés
les américains qui étaient bien
incapables de rembourser
et là je vous montre une petite
similitudes avec ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en règle à nouveau un
problème économique par de la dette et
par là pour le coup un excès de bêtes
qui nous retombera sur le nez un d'eux
de manière violente et durable
qu'est ce qu'il va faire pour éviter
cette cette dette
qu'est ce qu'il aurait fallu faire
gérait le la crise du coronavirus
autrement stasia vous savez vous savez
combien coûte un masque ffp2 en chine
il coûte 9 centimes d'euro d'accord il
coûte 9 centimes d'euro alors imaginons
que on les fasse faire en france puisque
monsieur mac on nous a dit que c'était
la guerre en temps de guerre on
réquisitionne des sociétés et on leur
fait faire des masses donc même si
vraiment on voulait leur fait les faire
payer deux fois trois fois le prix
chinois
eh bien ça coûterait quelque chose comme
40 40 50 millions d'euros
et alors qu'est ce que c'est par rapport
à ce qu'on est en train de mettre sur la
table des centaines de
il y a si tout le monde avait un masque
si on faisait des tests à tout le monde
vous savez combien ça coûterait te faire
des tests à toute la population
française
135 euros par tête qu'est ce que ça fait
135 euros par tête
ça vous fait aller 8 milliards 8
milliards d'euros
si vous avez un milliard d'euros par
rapport à ce qu'on est en train de
dépenser par rapport à ce qu'on est en
train de faire économiquement à coup de
centaines de milliards d'euros de dette
qu'il va falloir on va supporter chacun
nous valent supporter on pas se prendre
des impôts ça va être épouvantable on
veut notre épargne pourquoi parce que
c'est mal géré olivier on remarque une
courte pause on revient dans un instant
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez on parle de l'union européenne
après un premier échec à des
négociations à le 7 avril deux jours
plus tard le 9 donc les ministres des
finances des 27 pays de l'union
européenne se sont réunis en
visioconférence ils se sont entendus sur
une réponse économique commune à la
crise juste après sur twitter bruno le
maire le ministre français de l'économie
a salué cet accord au total près de 550
milliards d'euros vont pouvoir être
utilisé pour limiter l'impact de cette
crise un plan composé de trois volets il
a d'abord ce soutien aux pme avec la bei
la banque européenne d'investissement
elle pourra mobiliser jusqu'à 200
milliards d'euros pour les entreprises
grâce à un fonds de garantie apportée
par les états pour aider les pays à
financer à leurs dispositifs de chômage
partiel la commission européenne
pourrait lever jusqu'à 100 milliards
d'euros et puis les pays en difficulté
pouvant pourront avoir accès au
mécanisme européen de stabilité ce
dispositif a créé en 2002 au moment de
la faillite de la grèce sert notamment à
aider les états à qui n'arrivent plus à
se financer sur les marchés et s'agit en
gros de prêter aux états jusqu'à 2% de
leur pib soit jusqu'à 240 milliards
d'euros pour l'ensemble de la zone
euros alors à l'issue de la réunion du 9
avril bruno le maire s'est réjoui un de
ce plan adepte de l'union européenne
qu'il qualifie d' un pas majeur vers
plus de solidarité européenne quel est
votre avis à vous olivier sur ce plan en
trois volets visiblement bruno le bruno
le maire c'est l'heureux de la crèche
excusez moi mais alors déjà vous arrête
tout de suite les 500 milliards
il y en a une bonne partie qui sont des
garanties sur des prêts éventuels
garanties sur des prêts éventuels ça
veut dire qu'encore une fois qu'est ce
qu'on fait on met de la dette parce
qu'on n'en avait pas assez 1 donc on met
encore une fois de la dette
simplement il faudrait quand même que
les gens finissent par comprendre que la
dette
ça vous aliens ça donne les clés de chez
vous soit aux banquiers soit l'état
d'accord tout la dette que vous à que
vous ferez aujourd'hui vous allez d'une
manière ou d'une autre la rembourser
d'accord ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que vous pouvez vous préparer joule
annonces à l'avancé vous pouvez vous
préparer d'ici la fin de l'année à un
impôt qui sera un impôt exceptionnel
alors une sorte d sf si vous voulez mais
très probablement bien a baissé en
termes de seuil pour pouvoir toucher le
maximum de la population et qu'on vous
présentera en disant il faut ça pour
redresser la france
après le virus donc vous l'aurez
et ça je peux vous le garantir vous
l'aurez et vous aurez d'autres moyens de
vous prendre votre est pas parce que il
va falloir rembourser toute cette folie
de prêts à droite et à gauche qui je
vous le dis et je vous le répète
n'aurait pas été nécessaire
si cette crise avait été gérée
correctement par des gens qui n'auraient
pas enfiler un costume beaucoup trop
grand pour eux olivier rarement sur le
troisième
oled cet accord qui a suscité à de
nombreux désaccords entre les pays du
sceau du sud et du nord c'est l'accès au
mécanisme européen de stabilité
notamment avec les pays bas qui ont leur
poids à qui l'on a reproché de bloquer
le sujet pourquoi concrètement est ce
que les pays-bas n'était pas n'était pas
étaient réticents à l'activation de ce
mécanisme
parce que le ms est une vraie
cochonneries c'est à dire que il faut
savoir quelle est la contrepartie on
vous présente ça comme un fonds de
secours en mai allez demander aux grecs
1 ce qu'ils en pensent du ms c'est à
dire que la contrepartie de l'argent
qu'on vous prête qu on a versé au
préalable parce qu'il faut quand même
savoir que ce fonds est abondé par tous
les pays
donc en fait on vous reprenez votre
argent 1
la france par exemple c'est 140
milliards qui sont versés aux us et le
ms d'ailleurs peut demander à tout
moment une contribution supplémentaire à
tous les pays et vous n'avez même pas le
droit de refuser
c'est un truc de fou et et le ms quand
ils vous prête de l'argent
eh bien ils vous demandent en
contrepartie un certain nombre de choses
donc en fait vous n'êtes plus dirigeante
votre pays
les dirigeantes votre pays sont les
dirigeants du ms qui prennent la main et
qui vous impose un certain nombre de
choses
lise avez vu on a vu ce que ça donnait
en grèce
je suis pas sûr que les italiens et très
envie de passer sous direction du msc
les pays bas qui étaient réticents a
alors lancé d'abord été réticent les
pays-bas à au corona bon donc avec
l'allemagne d'ailleurs qui était
réticente au corps en un bond pourquoi
parce que ça mutualisé encore une fois
les pertes si vous voulez c'est à dire
vous utilisiez le l'emprunt entre eux
entre les pays du sud justement et les
pays qui se pensent vertueux comme les
pays bas ou l'allemagne donc il n'avait
pas du tout envie de contribuer à sa sur
le ms
nous demandez pas pourquoi les pays bas
a été et est contre ou pas j'en sais
rien la seule chose que je peux vous
dire c'est que doit il ya un pays qui va
être contre l'utilisation du msc
l'italie c'est l'italie pourquoi parce
qu'elle n'a pas du tout envie de donner
les clés de chez elle à des dirigeants
du mcs voilà donc et pourtant c'est
c'est vraiment là là là
le msc le centre d'une espèce de poésie
de politique de fédéralisme et de donner
les clés à une des gens qui ne sont pas
élus encore une fois les gens qui ne
sont pas élus comme la commission
européenne et c'est l'italie qui
soutient ajustements à cette idée de
cornavin
est ce que c'est une bonne idée selon
vous non parce que c'est toujours la
même chose si vous vous laissez c'est
encore une fois ce se diluer dans une
dette alors évidemment les italiens
voient une chose c'est que s'il ya des
corps en avance comme il y aura dedans
la garantie de l'allemagne la garantie
de la france qui ont des taux plus bas
que les taux italiens qui sont 1,5 pour
cent et bien ils se disent on va comme
ça pouvoir emprunter avec avec un taux
qui sera beaucoup plus bas mais mais ça
c'est pas en je vous dis c'est pas en
rajoutant encore une fois de la dette
que vous allez régler les choses ont ils
sont à 135% de dettes les italiens donc
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on va
finir probablement l'année ils vont être
pas loin des 150 voire même un peu plus
et tous les pays ça va être la même
chose
donc en fait on est en train est
exactement de faire ce qu'a fait le
japon
à un moment dans les années 90 et dans
les années 2000 et qui a abouti à ce que
le japon aujourd'hui et 250 % de son pib
en dettes vous disent pas il faut
s'imaginer après qu'on a pas de
croissance on ferait de la dette on
aurait 5% ou 6% ou 7% de croissance ça
poserait aucun problème
mais aujourd'hui on n'a pas cette
croissance là on a une démographie qui
est en berne et qui va l'être encore
plus très probablement après la crise
parce que même si un confinement et que
les gens n'ont rien d'autre à faire mais
ça n'empêche qu'aujourd'hui ils ont peur
de l'avenir et que ça m'étonnerait
qu'ils fassent beaucoup de bébés donc on
va avoir exactement comme après la crise
de 2008
une plongée de la démographie encore une
fois sur des sur des taux qui sont déjà
très bas donc on a peu de croissance
on va avoir une dette qui va exploser à
la hausse
comment fait-on alors il n'ya pas il n'y
a pas 36 solutions je vous dis on va
déjà collé des impôts partout pour
essayer de rattraper la chose et puis en
plus de ça vous aurez ils ont
certainement l'idée que ça se finira en
hyperinflation et pas du tout en
refusant en défaut de paiement sur la
dette parce que ça c'est à un petit peu
plus compliqué politiquement non ça sera
très probablement une une hyperinflation
une chute de confiance une chute de
confiance dans la dent les autorités une
chute de confiance dans la monnaie et à
ce moment là vous aboutirez à ce qui
s'est passé au venezuela ou en argentine
voyez juste une dernière question avant
de passer aux questions à cash quelle
leçon a lieu doit-elle tirer de cette
crise
quelle leçon de lieux de doit-elle tirer
de cette crise c'est que à force de se
de la tête des gens finalement ça
vous revient dans la figure
allez on passe vocation cash
chaque semaine olivier delamarche
réponses aux questions que vous lui
posez d'ailleurs n'hésitez pas à les
envoyer via les réseaux sociaux avec le
hashtag rta cash première question
olivier alexis 185 olivier qu'avez-vous
à penser de l'allocution d'emmanuel
macron sur le déconfinement 27 minutes
pour ne rien dire à part une date 11 mai
mais on sait pas on sait pas comment ça
se fera peut-être que les enfants
retourneront à l'état à l'école
peut-être pas peut-être que l'ondé
confinera une certaine partie peut-être
pas vingt-sept minutes pour ne rien dire
tm question olivier aurélien le vigan la
question que je me pose toujours quand
j'entends monsieur de la marche ou un
autre nous parler des taxes sur
l'essence est la suivante s'il était au
pouvoir est ce qu'il supprimerait cet
axe l'écouté il faut quand même se
rendre compte un petit peu de ce que
c'est le pétrole brut
et quand on vous dit que le pétrole
coûte 25 dollars le baril
est ce que vous savez combien il ya
litres de pétrole dans un bar il y en à
159 litres d'accord donc ça vous fait
une énergie à 15 centimes d'euros 15 pas
pardon 15 centimes de dollars c'est
presque la même chose mais 15 centimes
de dollar le litre donc une énergie qui
est franchement pas cher avec un baril
de 159 litres de pétrole vous fait un
petit peu plus de 70 litres d'essence
d'accord cette essence elles vous
revient hors taxes à quelque chose comme
38 centimes toujours sur la base d'un
pétrole à 25 dollars il est même plus
bas aujourd'hui donc 35 centimes 38
centimes le
le litre aujourd'hui vous payez votre
essence en 1 30
est ce que vous trouvez normal que sur
un coup de dé sens d'un 38 vous ayez ou
d'un 30 vous ayez 38 centimes de coûts
du pétrole du de l'essence et un euro de
taxe
enfin ccc c'est un cauchemar
or excusez moi mais enfin on est le seul
pays comme ça on est le seul pays à
mettre autant de taxes sur le pétrole
donc comment font les autres ils y
arrivent
les autres n'ont pas les mêmes prix sur
l'essence donc excusez moi mais oui si
j'étais aux commandes
le prix de l'essence n'aurait pas autant
de taxes merci à beaucoup olivier c'est
la fin de cette émission à merci de
l'avoir suivi sachez que nos précédents
numéros sont disponible en replay sur
notre site internet à l'adresse ft
france pointe tv olivier votre mois de
la fin la prochaine fois que vous avez
27 minutes et que vous ne savez pas quoi
faire
regardez notre émission plutôt que les
discours de monsieur macro